on le sait que le prix du panier
augmente mais pas mal plus que vous le
pensez voici comment l'industrie s'y
prend pour nous faire payer plus cher
sans trop qu'on s'en rende compte
[Musique]
vous avez l'impression que vous en avez
de moins en moins pour votre argent en
faisant votre épicerie vous avez raison
la régulation ne date pourtant pas
d'hier j'étais à l'école primaire
ma mère acheter une boîte de biscuits
qui était d'habitude d'un certain
glandeurs puis on s'aperçoit que ça
entre dans le tiroir et avant ça
n'aurait pas
comme les consommateurs sont très
sensibles à une hausse de coûts les
entreprises essaient de maintenir le
prix des aliments et pour y arriver
la régulation est parfois la seule
option possible il n'y a pas de miracle
ça me coûte
pour rester en vie faut qu'il ya quand
même une marge de rentabilité
c'est l'épaule sommes bien déterminés
on n'a pas le choix on doit repasser la
facture au client le système agro
alimentaire tant sur le plan mondial que
local au fait face dans les dernières
années à une tempête parfaite donc on a
eu la pandémie pressions inflationnistes
et la guerre en ukraine qui vient
ajouter aux troubles et aux défis
auxquels doit faire face l'industrie et
lorsqu'on fait face à une augmentation
d'un ou deux courants le coût des
ingrédients par exemple on eu quelques
actions qu'on peut poser mais là on a
une pression inflationniste sur à peu
près tous les coupes c'est un secteur
qui est tellement compétitif
personne ne veut être le premier à les
augmenter le prix affichés sur les
tablettes d'épicerie donc si on
travaille pas sur les revenus ben ça
laisse l'autre côté de la médaille il
faut travailler sur les coûts et les
astuces sont nombreuses pour déjouer
l'oeil du consommateur comme diminuer
graduellement les quantités il ya des
choses
qui sont assez évidentes au fil des ans
on a vu la recette minceur de certains
produits l'on ait vu comment voir et
diminuer c'est parce qu'il sait qui
c'est la nostalgie qui nous fait penser
qu'on est déjà eu des formats beaucoup
plus important pour ces remblais bongo
quand on était plus jeune il y en avait
plus ou si le jugement est rendu avec
des emballages de bartok de sync une
white et la transition se fait de façon
tellement délicate où une naturelle si
je puis dire que le consommateur ne
réalise pas
moi je suis italienne j'achète les
pattes avant le format était 500 grammes
et lever 950 maintenance et 4,5 g il
faut aussi être attentif à la grosseur
des emballages une boîte plus
volumineuse ne peut pas dire qu'ils
aient leur compte y est plus léonie note
cheerios là on voit qu'on à 430 grammes
une boîte qui est quand même assez large
qui risquent de se différencier sur les
tablettes alors qu'ici borné dans le 440
grammes puis la boîte est un petit peu
plus petites dont on a 10 grammes de
plus mais format plus plus gros de ce
côté là les magnifiques turier eu aussi
des géniaux hésité avec le format des
contenants si un endroit où sa fondue si
bien la ligue 1 oui parce que dans des
emballages comme ça on a plusieurs trucs
pour jouer là pour venir enlever
quelques grammes des fois ça va être une
incantation au fond du produit du
contenant qui va nous permettre d'aller
gagnant 5 à 10 grammes l'épaisseur là
ici du couvercle la forme on va on va
mincir ou dans une petite cure
tentation dans le cas du café toutes les
marques utilisent sensiblement le même
contenant pourtant donc on est de 226 à
326 pour un format qui est presque
identique les marques maison avait un
petit peu le haut du pavé dans ce sens
là parce que leur structure de coûts
étaient différentes donc les marques
maison était souvent les dernières à
utiliser ces stratagèmes là comme la
régulation mais maintenant on commence à
voir des marques maison qui dans la
crème dans votre biscuits on va
peut-être enlever un quelques grands
mots pour justement maintenir ces
fameuses marges
substituer des ingrédients par d'autres
de qualité moindre est aussi une façon
de réduire les coûts de production les
fromages analogue fait d'huile de palme
en sont un bel exemple mais il y en a
plusieurs autres
bah on pourrait utiliser des substituts
donc des substances laitières modifier
ce qui nous permet de retirer certains
ingrédients bien sûr on va vouloir le
faire sans altérer la texture parce que
dans les produits laitiers c'est souvent
très important c'est ça que
consommateurs remarque en plus du goût
on peut aussi au niveau des sucres
ajoutés certains ingrédients tout à fait
naturel qui nous permettent de mettre un
peu moins sud donc lui un bon goûter de
ce point de vue là mais au total ça
vient diminuer nos coûts de production
est ce que l'industrie a le droit à
notre insu de diminuer la quantité dans
un emballage ou encore de modifier la
liste d'ingrédients le prix est là c'est
juste que le contenant la mesure du
poids bien là doit changer donc c'est
légal
c'est comme si on exigeait des
transformateurs vendée nous même pris
tout le temps peu importe vos
augmentations de prix je dire c'est
comme si on disait son ramène soit au
niveau personnel travaille toujours pour
le même taux aura parce que sinon c'est
un honneur il ya qui semble qu'ils
impliquent la logique ne fonctionne plus
vivre alors c'est les gars maintenant
c'est légal mais ce que c'est normal
qu'on soit frustré
on peut être frustré mais il faut
[Musique]
il faut faire attention c'est tout je
pense que beaucoup de gens bizarres
c'est la solution facile non ce n'est
pas il ya plusieurs entreprises qui ne
veulent pas s'en aller là dedans parce
que c'est un peu un cul-de-sac
malheureusement une fois qu'on le fait
on peut pas revenir en arrière au temps
pour l'entreprise que pour le
consommateur donc faut faire face à la
musique il faut vraiment user de
créativité lorsqu'on fait de tapisserie
c'est pour aider les consommateurs que
sos cuisine a créé une plateforme
internet et une application qui compare
le prix des aliments et propose les
meilleurs rabais nous on surveille les
prix depuis dix ans on a des millions de
points de repère alors vous entrez la
donner et puis vous allez voir tous les
formats donc été positionnés sur le
forme en courant mais vous pouvez voir
les autres ça va vous dire si c'est bon
ou si c'est pas bon on n'a pas vraiment
le choix comme concerne on ne sait même
pas faites vos calculs regarder le prix
au kilo et au lit
[Musique]